oh he made a stir on Friday Donna McNabb
was on TMZ and he and he said I'm a Hall
of Fame I should be in the Hall of Fame
my numbers speak for themselves my
numbers are better in Troy Aikman's and
you know there are some people who agree
that McNabb eventually should get in
most people disagree though Chris and
you and I have talked about this in the
past and McNabb from time to time will
bang on that that concept of him being a
Hall of Famer first of all I don't think
that they look to each his own I don't
know that the case becomes more
persuasive when he's the one who says it
I'd rather someone else make the case
for him either way I don't think he's
he's a hall-of-famer I don't think his
career can pay compares favorably to the
other guys from his era who are clearly
going to get in he's gonna be like a
Tony Romo maybe even nei Manning who is
just on the outside looking in yeah no I
agree I mean I think you like Manning
will ultimately get in because of you
know two Super Bowls that will get him
over the hump there but Donald the name
on the Jersey helps too well of course
it does exactly right there's no doubt
about that you know Donald McNabb not
having won a Super Bowl did some awesome
things through his career it's really
close it's a very good conversation yeah
I think I kind of leaned like where you
are he's on the outside looking in he's
an NFL legend but he's not an NFL Hall
of Famer you know and again
you know I think I look at it and really
context matters a little bit that's
where I think people miss out sometimes
in these conversations you know I know
oh it's easy to look at career stats in
the way McNabb played and Troy Aikman
played well Troy Aikman was asked and
played a whole different style of
football than down to look down and
Donovan McNabb got you know Andy Reed in
the passing explosion career like you
said and you know really at the very
least to you know Don this is where the
context matter Don McNab at times was
all over the place with his
I mean there was there was years where
yeah Philadelphia found ways to get in
the playoffs
even though Donovan McNabb not wasn't
necessarily honest a game it was like he
could only throw a screen to Westbrook
or a bomb down the field but anything in
between
you know intermediate accurate type
throws there the ball was all over the
place so where Andy we had to manage on
in McNabb at times that way too so to me
it's just a little bit all over the
place and yes they were highly
competitive course when he was the
quarterback of the Philadelphia Eagles
but I think it's again
lack of big wins and more kind of oh we
lost in big moment type of situations I
think ultimately that will keep him out
of the Hall of Fame I've got four
ingredients that I will put into this
this pot for the purposes of trying to
figure out whether or not a quarterbacks
a hall-of-famer statistics longevity
domination and championships and you
don't have to have all four but I think
you have to have a lot of one if you're
gonna have none of the other if you have
any championships you better have the
longevity and the statistics and that
domination that's striking fear into the
opponent's hearts keeping them up late
at night trying to game plan against the
guy but just look at stats and longevity
right his numbers may be better than
Aikman x' but his numbers are about
twenty fifth all-time in passing yardage
thirtieth all-time in passing touchdowns
playing for a pass happy head coach for
his career and what these numbers aren't
higher he didn't play all that long
relative to other quarterbacks drafted
in 1999 he was out of the league by the
middle of the 2011 season that is not
longevity as quarterbacks go not when he
got Tom Brady playing 20 years that's
not playing long enough to have the body
of work that allows you to walk right
through the front door to the Hall of
Fame no exactly right you're right I
mean it was a lot of awesome kind of or
really good years smashed in the middle
of there but yeah a little bit all over
the place that way and you know you said
it I mean Andy Reed as we've seen runs
an offense that's very quarterback
friendly I mean let's not forget you
know two years ago Alex Smith led the
NFL in passing with the Kansas City
Chiefs why Patrick mahomes was sitting
on the bench
Alec Smith was the number one rated
quarterback in football
so that just you know a little inkling
into what Andy Reed can do and yeah I
think Andy Reid is responsible for some
of the things that you know Donovan
McNabb went through when I talked about
the struggles you know I think those
struggles would have been far greater if
he didn't have a guy like Andy Reed who
could deliver up some silver platter
type plays and completions at times when
McNabb did hit those kind of
inconsistent times in the season or in
his career you know he started off his
career extremely well five straight Pro
Bowl appearances from 2000 through 2004
and obviously four straight NFC
championship games a Super Bowl
appearance but it really fell off for
him in 2005 that was the year he was
dealing with the hernia most of the
season finally shut it down and only had
one Pro Bowl appearance from 2005
through the end of his career so that
back half of his career was not good and
and just ultimately not good enough to
get into the Hall of Fame and and you
know maybe at some point years from now
wants all of the guys who are going to
get maybe he's that maybe he's a senior
committee candidate you know one of the
guys that they take a look back after
the passage of decades and say this is a
guy from that era who should have gotten
in but but you got some great
quarterbacks in this era who played at
or about the time McNabb did Brady
Peyton Manning Drew Brees Philip Rivers
Ben Roethlisberger at some point you
have to draw the line and say no more
yeah I think Eli Manning is the guy and
you know Chris I want your thoughts on
this Sherwin Williams who's one of the
Hall of Fame voters she thinks that
these mediocre years tacked onto the end
of Eli Manning's career actually could
keep him from getting in do you think
that that's playing for another year or
two and not playing well should count
against the great things you did well
yeah yeah I mean it's your career I mean
that's the way it is you know and and
really Eli's another fascinating topic I
mean I think the career is itself if we
took away the two Super Bowls we'd go no
way see NFL Hall of Fame quarterback
there's no way he had two runs that were
special and that's of course gonna bring
us into that conversation we're talking
about a quarterback who's you know close
to 500 career winning record you know
Eli Manning's never won a home playoff
game in fact I don't think he's won a
playoff game in general other than the
two years they've won the Super Bowl
you know since they won this
Birbal in 2011 no quarterback has led
the NFL Eve's the NFL and losses
interceptions there's a number a few
other stats that are not glaring or you
know good look for him altogether so
Eli's going to get in because of the two
Super Bowls because of the magnitude of
those moments against the Patriots and
because of his last name like you said
but I think it's also very debatable
whether he deserves to be in or not well
I think he's the last one in from that
era and I don't think McNabb or Romo or
anyone else who would be in the Hall of
very good is going to end up in the Hall
of Fame
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports